モグ...............モグ.....................
ﾃﾞｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪﾝ
ﾊﾞｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧﾝ
この刑務所に来て　早くも５年が経った
この刑務所は...........
変だ（確信）
俺たちの囚人服は..........
なぜかとても可愛く
この刑務所に来てから
俺はバナナ（意味深 ）が好きになった
５年間の長年の努力の末
この刑務所からの脱出方法を見出した
今日はついに　この脱出手段を.........
実行にｳﾂｩｩｽ！
ｶﾁｬ
（ﾆﾔｯ）
ﾃﾞｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪﾝ
ﾃﾞｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪﾝ（高音）
モグ.......モグ.......モグ.......モグ......
ゲームスタート
Run For Free
ー 逃走中 ー
ﾀﾞｯﾀﾞｯﾀﾞｯﾀﾞｯﾀﾞｯﾀﾞｯ..........
ダッダッダッダッダッダッダッダッダン！
ﾌｭﾝ
（？）
ハァ............ハァ............
ｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞ
ﾃﾞｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪﾝ
ｷｬｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧ
モグ....モグ....モグ....
ﾀｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧﾝ（高音）
ｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞ
ﾎﾟｯ
ﾁｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰﾝ
ﾄﾞｺﾞｯ
ｶﾞﾁｬｧﾝ
ｶﾞﾁｬｶﾞﾁｬｶﾞﾁｬｧｧﾝ
ｶﾞﾁｬｶﾞﾁｬｧﾝ
ｶﾞﾁｬｧｧｧｧｧﾝ
（ファンファーレ）
ﾌﾝﾌﾝ
ﾌﾝ
ｳﾞｭﾝ
ﾊﾞｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧﾝ
ｽﾞｩｩｩｩｩｩｩｩｩｩｩｩﾝ
んぅ〜ん
バナナ〜
んぅ〜↑ん
ｶﾞﾁｬｯ
ﾊﾞﾅｧﾅｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧ
うるせぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇ！！！
ｽﾞｩｩｩﾝ
はい　というわけで見てくださって
ありがとうございました
今回の動画は見てもらったらわかると思うんですけど
も
僕の見た目が......
☆ミニオン☆
まさきがえーと刑務所の人みたいな感じで
その
大脱走っていうお話だったんですけど
も×２
なぜこういうお話を撮ったかと言いますと
本日公開の「怪盗グルーのミニオン大脱走」との
コラボ動画でございまーす　はい（パチパチパチ）
映画のタイトルにもある通り
「大脱走」ということで
まあ僕がミニオンの格好して大脱走してたわけなんですけど
も×３
まあまさきがね
こう　なんかそれっぽくなったと思うんですけど
も×４
これ実際似たようなシーンも映画の中で出て来るかもしれないです
まあ僕よりもはるかに可愛いと思われるミニオンが
映画の中で出て来ると思うので
是非みなさん　劇場で....にて！観てみてください
そして映画の詳しい情報は
動画の概要欄にありますので是非そちらも
チェックして見てください
ミニオンの映画誰とでも楽しめる映画だと思うので
是非
友達とでも、家族とでも
恋人でも
観てくだっさい！
ﾊﾞ↓ﾅ↑ﾊﾞ↓ﾅ↑ﾊﾞ↓ﾅ↑ﾊﾞ↓ﾅ↑ﾊﾞ↓ﾅ↑ﾊﾞ↓ﾅ↑ﾊﾞ↓ﾅ↑ﾊﾞ↓ﾅ↑
バーーナバナナーバナー
バナナナーーバナナバーナナー
バナナナーバーナナ
バナナバーナーナー
バッナッナッナ
☆バ☆ナ☆ナ☆ナ☆